same way Kennedy prepared for his
debates with a blowjob and a cup of
coffee
no teller and I have done so many shows
we are figuring the other day that I
think it's possible teller and I
certainly together we've done more shows
together on stage more hours of shows
together on stage that I believe anyone
alive I think if we keep going another
10 or 20 years which we certainly hope
too it'll be more than anyone ever has
individually we spent a lot of time on
stage so because of that you know I went
on stage the night my child was born one
of them the other one was born when I
had vacation I went on stage the night
my mom died I went on stage the night my
dad died I want to stage the night my
sister died I've gone on stage and I've
pulled IVs out of my arm left the
hospital gone on stage gone back and
went back on morphine I have done shows
during horrible emotional breakups I've
done shows when exhausted and after
you've been through however many shows
you've done what would it's with twenty
thousand you know tens of thousands of
shows maybe more than that you no longer
prepare you know we would be backstage
off-broadway we shared a backstage area
with the gentlemen who were doing a
Steppenwolf show you know and wonderful
wonderful actors I mean fabulous actors
tremendous I mean much better actors
than us I mean we're not even actors we
share the backstage area and the great
thing was that they would be there 45
minutes before the show meditating and
going into red leather yellow leather
red leather yellow leather and working
with their whole instrument you know
everything prepared and Teller and I
would be just finishing up tying our
ties while reading and walk onstage
directly in the middle of a conversation
we'd be having about a movie we saw on
TV last night no preparation whatsoever
and it's just because well I like to
think it's just because
we had done so many more shows than they
had but you might also think it's
because they're better than we are
I think either answer could be you can
make an argument for